[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mardi 20 novembre
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal de tv 78
tout de suite les titres de l'actualité
locale
une opération délicate qui s'est
réalisée sous des conditions météo
difficiles le premier tronçon de la
passerelle reliant mantes-la-jolie à
lima a été posée hier un ouvrage dédié
aux piétons et cyclistes soulevé grâce à
une grue de 86 mètres des images
impressionnantes à retrouver au début de
cette édition
les élections européennes se tiennent en
mai 2019 et la campagne des municipales
en 2020 aussi se prépare la france
insoumise vient de lancer son comité
d'appui pour les deux scrutins à
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
pour en parler en plateau catherine
bayle est qui et qui en est la co
animatrice et puis il va fêter 40 ans de
scène le groupe trust sera samedi à la
merise attrape les interprètes
d'antisocial se sont reformés en 2016 et
ont sorti cette année un nouvel album
c'est le coup de coeur culturel de la
semaine invite également tout à l'heure
les membres de belo horizonte capoeira
les 16e rencontres internationales de la
discipline se tienne ce samedi à
elancourt la mobilisation des gilet
jaune contre la hausse des carburants
persistent notamment dans les yvelines
après des rassemblements samedi et
dimanche une nouvelle action spontanée a
été menée hier sur le péage de l'a 13 à
buchelay pas de barrages filtrants cette
fois ci mais une opération séduction
auprès des routiers avec qui elle et
manifestants ont échangé d'autres
actions péage gratuit pourrait se
prolonger cette semaine un blocage du
dépôt de carburant de gargenville est
également envisagée dans le nord des
yvelines également le voici posé le
premier tronçon de la grande passerelle
reliant mantes-la-jolie à ali mais en
voix douce a été donc posé hier une
opération délicate pour un chantier qui
a débuté en février dernier qui va se
poursuivre marylène yapi chine où il est
arrivé sur une barge
le premier tronçon de la grande
passerelle a pris place l'un des 19
novembre sur le pont reliant la place de
l'étape à mantes-la-jolie au théâtre de
verdure de l'île aux dames c'est une
une opération extrêmement délicate qui
prend 48 heures pendant 48 euros qu'une
péniche ne passera sur ce bras de seine
pour pouvoir faciliter cette
installation 105 mètres de long et 7 m
de large pour une passerelle total de
201 m réservé aux piétons et aux
cyclistes
elle entre dans un projet global en
faveur de la mobilité douce de 9,6
millions d'euros financé en majorité par
la région ile de france le département
des yvelines a contribué à 11%
la la la mise en route de cette
passerelle correspond à cette volonté de
faire que ce lieu traditionnel de
passage d'une rive à l'autre remplisse
toutes les fonctions qui sont les
siennes dans la société d'aujourd'hui
la structure est en acier et elle est
revêtue de bois l'architecte l'a imaginé
comme une terrestre reliant le centre
ville de mantes la jolie et de lits mais
que les décès mais on repart avec le
point existant qui est un pont routier
qui est un endroit en fait assez assez
lourd assez présente dans le site nous
c'est que les jeunes se veut un cv douce
avait un peu juste en ambulance pour
être en harmonie avec le fleuve avec le
paysage le chantier devrait prendre fin
à aller vers 2019
cette passerelle correspond à la
première étape du nouveau franchissement
entre les deux villes le vieux pont
situé de l'autre côté sera rénové et
agrémenté lui aussi d'une passerelle
les deux ouvrages seront ensuite relié
par un cheminement piéton et cyclable
sur l'île aux dames on ouvre une page
politique il sera candidat pour un
quatrième mandat à trappes guy malandra
guy malandain un pardon briguera bien sa
propre succession à la mairie en 2020
l'élu socialiste de 81 ans l'a annoncé
hier lundi une décision prise après
quelques mois de réflexion
s'il est réélu dit malandain ne restera
pas pour autant mer pendant les six
années de son mandat il souhaite aller
notamment jusqu'à la fin est des travaux
d'enfouissement de la nationale 10
prévus en 2021 2022 et passer la main
ensuite un maire adjoint qui se formera
ses côtés guy malandain est à la tête de
la municipalité depuis 2001 les
élections municipales qui ne sont pas
programmées qu'en 2020 elle se prépare
déjà également du côté de l'opposition
deux trappes pas de déclaration de
candidature officielle encore mais une
prise de position claire pour othman nas
roulait lui les républicains déjà en
lice lors du scrutin de 2014
pourrait de nouveau se présenter à la
mairie et peut-être pas sous l'étiquette
et l'air et dans un courrier adressé aux
trappistes ce week-end othman nassr ou
affirme que l'avenir de la ville ne peut
passer par une opposition stérile il
faut un rassemblement il appelle je cite
toutes les bonnes volontés à se
rassembler et travailler ensemble et ce
au delà de leurs clivages politiques fin
de citation des élections municipales
déjà dans les têtes donc tout comme le
prochain scrutin les élections
européennes se tiennent le 26 mai 2019
pour mener sa campagne de terrain dans l
es2 pour les deux élections la france
insoumise vient de le lancer un comité
d'appui sur le bassin versailles saint
quentin en yvelines pour en parler
catherine bayle est bon soir enfin vous
êtes co animatrice de ce comité d'appui
alors pour vous un soumi militants aussi
comme sympathisant c'est un nouveau
temps électoral fort qui s'ouvre à
présent après les présidentielles et les
législatives en 2010 est absolument
puisque l'enjeu tout d'abord c'est de
démontrer de convaincre que ces
élections européennes sont avant tout
des élections et aussi des élections
nationales françaises pourquoi parce que
la politique est appliqué par le
président macron et son gouvernement est
de copier coller en fait des directives
de la commission européenne et donc
c'est pourquoi nous en ferons un
référendum anti macro aurait pu dire
anti commission européenne c'est
l'occasion pour vous pour aussi les
sympathisants de d'être de faire un vote
sanction sur la politique d' emmanuel
macron et notamment celles menées en
europe
exactement on voit bien aujourd'hui avec
les gilets jaunes mais aussi avec toutes
les catégories professionnelles qui
manifestent
hier les ambulanciers les professeurs
enfin je veux dire les agriculteurs on
voit bien qu'il y a
un effondrement du pays à cause de cette
politique d'abandon des classes
populaires
donc en fait la colère et l'exaspération
monte notre objectif l'enjeu majeur ce
sera effectivement de donner un contenu
politique à cette élection c'est à dire
de dire aux gens écoutaient si vous
voulez que cette politique continue
qu'on ferme des écoles qu'on ferme des
lits qu'on referme les postes à côté de
chez vous à voter macron wauquiez ou ou
le pen qui sont les politiques libérales
si au contraire vous pensez que on a
besoin d'amélioration de nos services
publics d'irrigation des transports
collectifs
on voit bien aujourd'hui que c'est la
problématique on peut pas taxer de
manière punitive
les gens qui sont obligés de prendre
leur voiture sous prétexte de se
repeindre en vert quoi il expliqué à ce
comité d'appui du coup sûr sur ces
bassins de versailles et saint quentin
en yvelines
alors c'est comité d'appui auront pour
mission si vous voulez d'organiser
d'orchestrer la campagne
il faut dire une chose c'est qu'ils sont
ouverts à toute personne qui pas
forcément les insoumis c'est à dire bien
sûr il y aura les militants de la france
insoumise sur ce bassin de vie mais à
tous ceux qui se reconnaissent dans nos
valeurs et dans notre projet politique à
savoir un projet humaniste écologique et
de progrès de justice sociale
donc en fait nous allons d'abord
commencé par mener la bataille de
l'inscription sur les listes électorales
puisque nous pour nous c'est très
important que le peuple s'approprie se
mobilisent autour de 73 % de votants
lors des dernières européennes en 2014
exactement 2012 pardon c'est important
de leur expliquer pourquoi il faut voter
les enjeux de ce scrutin
mais bien sûr parce qu'on voit bien à
quel à quel point la commission
européenne impact durement avec cette
politique d'abandon des classes
populaires et des territoires aussi
périphériques
on voit bien à quel point cela crée de
la précarisation
finalement quand on écoute les gilets
jaunes on entend bien que s'en va au
delà c'est la goutte de gasoil qui fait
déborder le lh la colère en fait si ce
que bien sûr les européennes sur le
sujet des européennes pourquoi se
mobiliser pour la france info mise on
sait que jean luc mélenchon on va dire
pendant la campagne de 2007 était pas
dire le candidat le plus pro européen il
a notamment beaucoup critiqué la
commission européenne c'est quoi
l'utilité pour vous quelle idée vous
voulez mettre en avant pendant cette
campagne
alors la première chose qu'il faut dire
c'est que nous sommes les seuls à dire
qu'il faut sortir des traités parce
qu'il ne faut pas raconter d'histoires
et donc on alerte les les électeurs sur
le fait que tous les partis qui leur
diront on vous promet une europe qui ne
rêvent que c'est à dire la liste au père
noël ça n'est pas vrai puisque les
députés européens n'ont pas le pouvoir
de changer les traités
donc nous nous disons il faut soit
sortir si nous pouvons des traités soit
leur désobéir quand nous serons
gouvernement ce que nous comptons bien
voir arriver en 2022 l'idée c'est quand
même d'avoir je veux dire d'aider des
mandats électoraux d'avoir des députés
pour le combat parce qu'on peut se poser
la question alors à quoi ça sert d'élire
des députés européens
et bien moi je crois qu'il faut regarder
par exemple ce qu'a fait notre député
européen
younous omarjee qui a déposé un
amendement et qui a réussi à mobiliser
derrière lui tous les progressistes au
parlement européen et à faire voter
l'interdiction de la pêche électrique et
donc nous voulons nous avons besoin de
députés deux combats entre combat est
prêt pour le combat dans ces cas là il
faut voter pour la france en soit c'est
pour les européennes si on termine nous
reste moins d'une minute sur les
municipales parce que le comité d'appui
aussi a aussi pour but de préparer c'est
le terrain pour ces municipales
vous visez notamment à 50 en ligne il ya
quatre villes prioritaires c'est trappe
dont on parlait juste avant avec une
nouvelle candidature pour guy malandain
elancourt monty negi en course et ça il
ya quatre villes veut centrer par la
pression alors essentiellement là pour
le moment se posent encore des questions
mais pour l'heure nous allons lancer dès
le mois prochain dès le mois de décembre
dont tu de comité d'appui là encore
ouvert à tous ceux qui voudront nous
rejoindre sur notre projet politique sur
trappe et guyancourt
alors pourquoi parce qu'on a des liens
très forts avec les associations le
réseau associatif
parce que les résultats des dernières
élections ont montré qu'il avait une
véritable aspiration attrapé à
guyancourt pour l'avenir en commun
l'autre notre programme et qui enfin
parce qu'on a beaucoup de militants sur
sept ce bassin de vie sont ces deux
villes merci à catherine bayle est
d'abord été avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes la co animatrice du comité
d'appui de la france un souvenir sur le
bassin versailles saint quentin en
yvelines après la politique l'économie
l'entreprise gennari ce groupe basé
actuellement à magny les hameaux a lancé
la construction de son futur siège à
guyancourt cette société spécialisée
dans l'accompagnement de ses clients de
ses clients dans leurs projets
d'innovation connaît une croissance
continue depuis 2011
les explications de nicolas nombre et
c'est le futur siège juillan courtois de
gennari ce groupe cette entreprise
saint-quentinoise transformer en cluster
en 2011 accompagne les grands groupes
dans leurs projets d'innovation avec
douze entités en perpétuelle évolution
20 millions d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires et 30 % de
croissance par an la société a besoin
d'agrandir son espace il était important
qu'on puisse donc construire qu'on
puisse construire un bâtiment qui
conviennent à la fois à notre
développement est très sec et aussi donc
à la capacité de créer un écosystème
d'innovation pouvoir donc pouvoir donc
proposé à des start-up pouvoir composer
à des dans un cadre de coordination
entre donc les nouvelles technologies
nouvelles façons de travailler donc
voilà on sera plus à l'aise chez nous
spécialisé sur la filière électronique
et des objets connectés generix group
propose des solutions pour le secteur de
l'automobile avec un état d'esprit
collaboratif avec les grandes
entreprises les pme ou encore les
startups reçu dans cet espace la bubble
farm l'important c'est de connaître
leurs problématiques d'apprendre les
découvrir quels sont leurs besoins et
répondant à leurs besoins il se trouve
que dans le monde de la voiture et de
l'électrique de l'électronique istoe de
l'objet connectés de la voiture autonome
vous imaginez bien qu'à ce moment il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de beaux coups
beaucoup de besoins beaucoup d'intérêt
c'est d'exercer l'activité d'open
innovation alors c'est un grand mot mais
qui vise effectivement à mettre en
relation dans le but d'innover des
grandes structures telles que des grands
groupes et des acteurs qui sont de
taille plus réduite mais qui aussi leurs
caractéristiques d'agilité que sont les
start up et les pme passer des
réflexions sur les la voirie du futur
comment arriver à rendre la voiture à la
voirie connectés interconnecté le sujet
de d'avenir creed engineering a rejoint
le cluster dès sa création en 2015 une
opportunité pour cette entité
travaillant sur la mobilité de demain
ça nous a permis de profiter des moyens
profiter des infrastructures du cluster
est aussi d'être dans un écosystème qui
a permis de développer de 2000 m² le
siège va passer à 4400 mètres carrés
déménagement prévu début 2010 montigny
le bretonneux s'est engagé dans la mise
en accessibilité de ses bâtiments depuis
deux ans la ville s'est attaquée depuis
quelques mois à la salle jacques brel le
point sur les travaux qui ont débuté cet
été avec patrick jacques de dixmude et
marylène ya piché dans les travaux ont
débuté en juillet dernier la salle
jacques brel
elle à montigny le bretonneux
entreprenait de se mettre aux normes
accessibilité pour les personnes en
situation de handicap
la première phase étant l'ascenseur et
puis après il va s'en suivre une
ouverture à l'intérieur de la salle pour
permettre aux personnes en situation de
handicap de pouvoir entrer par l'entrée
principale mais ensuite pouvoir
bénéficier de cet axe et ascenseurs par
l'intérieur pour accéder en bas de la
salle un ascenseur qui aujourd'hui est
bien visible toute la salle a été adapté
des sièges sont réservés et même la loge
est mise aux normes salariales vraiment
maintenant des définitions le le bardage
extérieur là on peut voir delà de la
cage de l'ascenseur un petit pot de faux
plafond et un pot de peinture mais on
est vraiment dans la phase finale
trois cent trente mille euros pour ces
travaux entièrement financé par la ville
qui devrait s'achever au mois de
décembre
une démarche loin d'être isolé depuis
deux ans la ville met aux normes ses
bâtiments
dernière en date l'école charles péguy à
montigny le bretonneux encore c'est un
projet dans les cartons depuis deux ans
les travaux de démolition de l'ancienne
école albert samain ont démarré dans le
quartier de lasours de riz il devrait se
terminer avant la fin de l'année le
groupe scolaire avait fermé en 2010 en
raison d'effectifs insuffisants en lieu
et place seront construits un pôle multi
accueil dédié à la petite enfance et des
pavillons dont certains en logement
social propos recueillis par patrick
jacques de dixmude
c'était une école 12 classes
élémentaires et classes maternelles et
donc ce site va faire place donc un
bâtiment petite enfance une crèche une
trentaine ou de berceaux qui va qui
devrait voir le jour donc dans les deux
années à venir est également donc sur la
partie qui sera libérée des pavillons
des pavillons en ville à l'est du sport
la grande fête de la capoeira se déroule
c'est habituel désormais en novembre à
elancourt le palais des sports a
accueilli samedi les 16e rencontres
internationales de la discipline pour en
parler mais ce retouché bonsoir un grand
soir vous êtes maître de capoeira
fondateur du groupe bel horizon de
capoeira à elancourt et vous êtes venu
avec deux élèves thalys lukasz dos
santos et alexis moreau bonsoir à vous
deux merci d'être présent sur ce plateau
alors déjà pour les téléspectateurs qui
ne
espacez rencontre vous venez depuis
plusieurs années sur nos plateaux ça
sert à quoi les rencontres
internationales de la capoeira
bon on y rencontre se refaire ça fait
pour le changement et pense à la dgrad
qu'est ce qu'on appelle on appelle les
baptêmes
20e c'est qu'on commence à récupérer
mais c'est pas de ceinture donc la danse
est sur facture nette cette rencontre
est en changement de ceinture ou aussi
on élève que déjà pratiqué déjà quelques
années et va changer les ceintures dans
sept jours nous passer dégrader c'est en
présence de grands maîtres de la
discipline il ya plusieurs grands
maîtres cette rencontre sa 16ème
rencontre
il ya comme home est grosse mais ce
dégoût jeunesse apec mais ce caméscope
basile mercenaires
mais selon à metz caen mais ce régime et
social compte remettre qu'à bord et
plupart des hôtels beaucoup des
contremaîtres aussi et des professeurs
ans autour du vch pays et de la france
aussi ils viennent d'europe du brésil
aussi brésil en leur gros m cette année
qui est présente mais soros et vient
essentiellement du brésil
bon là il fait en tournée et c'est déjà
déjà passé plusieurs fois et cette année
il vient pour cette septième rencontre
pour fanta c est participer avec nous à
l'adulation brésilien en france depuis
plus de 15 ans et vous êtes venu avec
ses tares brésilien dans vos valises
depuis que vous avez lancé le groupe bel
horizon capoeira est ce que vous avez le
sentiment que c'est un art qui attire de
plus en plus de personnes bien sûr donc
là on vous y arriver si en france en
2002 il depuis 2002 que je suis si
j'arrivais 2002 et ailleurs
quelques élèves aujourd'hui de 7 etienne
déjà qu'ils dorment à la bonne école ça
va passer pour moi en centaine d
adhérents qui va changer de grade est
passé de grade
pendant que la caméra c'est cette femme
en a marre des combats mais aussi un art
harmonieux et qui tout le monde pour des
pratiques et et un petit nom quelque
chose que l'amp est maussade et c'est un
art complet saml du sport de la danse du
chant
finalement il ya la culture brésilienne
aussi à travers cet ennui
vainqueur à l'angop tous un petit peu de
la danse de la musique des sons des
mouvements des combats de l'artistique
et acrobatique attendant qui a tous des
dons et en plus ça sent encore ça tu
pouvais pratiquer par tout le monde qui
pouvait arriver
ejike c'est un caprice on va interroger
vos élèves alexis d'abord qu'est-ce qui
vous plaît dans la caporale combien
depuis combien de temps vous pratiquez
la capoeira et qu'est ce qui vous plaît
dans cette discipline
ça fait maintenant cinq ans que je
préside la capoeira je vais commencer ma
sixième année et est ce que j'aime bien
dans la capoiera c'est le fait
d'apprendre vraiment un nouvel art de
combat
voilà c'est quelque chose de beau enfin
voila c'est vrai que on n'échange pas
mal entre les maîtres les élèves tout ça
en échange de ce qu'on sait c'est
magique et vous on est tous dans votre
formation de capoeira
justement je commence à être un peu gras
des internautes d'enfants j'ai bientôt
passer enfin je vais passer adultes une
fois que j'aurai un peu grandi quand
même mais oui en terme d' enfant je suis
gradés et alice vous alors vous avez été
près lester parce que vous êtes le 6
devait se retouchée mais qu'est ce qui
vous plaît dans la capoeira de pratiquer
l'art lors de votre peur finalement
alors moi j'ai commencé déjà longtemps
la jeune et 3 4 ans est ce qui me plaît
vraiment de ce sport c'est le côté
acrobatique vraiment j'aime ce que je
préfère à faire le plus de dents en fait
c'est des acrobaties et du coup ce
samedi là vous allez passer des grades
par mois parce que mon prochain gratter
il pu demander des responsabilités et je
dois encore grandir dans la capoeira
pour obtenir ce grade
ça vous fait quoi d'avoir ces grands
maîtres de la capoeira qui seront
présents à elancourt de pouvoir les
côtoyer est ce que c'est une richesse
pour vous ça va ça va vous apporter dans
votre nouveau de formation
de loin et il va nous apporter toujours
des nouvelles expériences de nouveaux
mouvements et c'est ça qu'on aime on
aime apprendre de nouvelles choses
c'est pareil oui c'est la première fois
que vous participez à ces rencontres non
non j'en ai déjà fait quelques jeunes et
c'est vraiment des nouvelles choses
qu'on apprend à chaque année chaque
année c'est quelque chose de bien il
s'agit ici votre prénom pardon j'ai
tendance à oublier vite mais être touché
si on vient sur le programme de la
journée on l'a dit ça permet de passer
de passer ces grades c'est aussi une
journée dédiée peut-être à des
démonstrations peut venir découvrir ce
qu'est la capoeira oui bien sûr en jeu
profite de profiter tous les jours dit
elle en cours et voilà il évite aussi un
côté pour venir voir qu'est-ce que c'est
la capoeira aucun pour elle va apporter
beaucoup de choses et voilà vous pouvez
aussi en jour je sais pas moi revit ni à
essayer fait cette activité et dans sept
jours si je profite aussi pour dire
comme on dit il ya là des maîtres il ya
contrat mais rien contre eux mais rien
contre eux mais incertains ou contre eux
mais ce perso ce contremaître c'est
bourré socialiste professeur qype le
versement à l'est pour ce derby c'est au
grand sutton you name only to come qui
vont être présent ce qu'on me disait un
musée lèvres tout saison et vient pour
vous montrer un petit plus de cette
période il ce travail qui est enrichie
un peu plus mon travail que cette hausse
la tendance là ils transmettent passer
des énergies
lens a beaucoup de choses à des biens
pour forte à l'essai et aussi qu'on dit
ça travaille branca par un essai 16e
rencontres internationales de la
capoeira estienne à elancourt ce samedi
c'est au palais des sports les horaires
est 9h à 18h merci m est retouché merci
annonçait lycée alexis pour votre
témoignage est donc on vous retrouvera
très vite dans ce journal est du
cyclisme direction le vélodrome national
de saint quentin en y
line un grand gala baptisé star en piste
qui était organisée samedi dernier le
concept des professionnels de la piste
ont affronté des cyclistes sur route
dans différentes épreuves reportage de
michael et demi d'euros et de nicolas
d'ambri un concept inédit au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
ce samedi 17 novembre les pistes un
français élites ont affronté des
routiers sur la piste dans une série
d'épreuves organisées sur une soirée ça
va se jouer à la et je pense
qu'on risque d'avoir des surprises sur
les épreuves d'endurance mais les pistes
à ont bien l'intention donc de relever
le défi et de se montrer à la hauteur
des routiers sur les épreuves
d'endurance et même chose sur les
épreuves de sprint où dans l'élimination
donc l'aller les routiers vont défier
nos sprinteurs l'expérience inscrits
dans le challenge assurances vélo a été
réalisée devant plus de 3000 personnes
c'est une bonne chose parce que déjà il
n'y a pas beaucoup d'événements
populaires et festifs en france voilà
avec des coureurs de renom
c'est une belle soirée une belle épreuve
ont beaucoup de plaisir
on profite on est plusieurs plusieurs
coureurs à se retrouver c'est un peu
inédit donc c'est assez bons et certains
cyclistes ont pu tester de nouvelles
disciplines dans la bonne humeur comme
sur cette course en tandem
je peux dire que j'ai pratiqué du keirin
recettes en tandem mais c'est des
sensations vraiment spécifique
une impression que le vélo se tordait un
peu dans tous les sens à l'arrière et je
sais pas les secours sont à l'avant au
niveau du pilotage
en tout cas c'est l'extra de pouvoir
découvrir cette discipline
un nouveau gala pourraient être
organisées dans les prochains mois selon
les organisateurs avec de nouvelles
épreuves au programme
[Musique]
pour terminer c'est le moment de
retrouver le coup de coeur culture de la
semaine avec mélanie pokémon soir
quarante ans de scène et toujours autant
d'engagement le groupe trust est de
retour sur scène mélanie poker ou les
écouter attrape tout simplement le
groupe mythique de rock joue samedi soir
le 24 novembre à la merise après 50 pose
de séparation plus précisément le groupe
se reforme en 2005 et en 2007 les cinq
membres donnent le ton de leur tournée
au nom de la rage tour
l'occasion aussi de découvrir leur
nouvel album le 10e dans le même sens
sorti cette année treize titres alors
alors style fidèles oui ils surprennent
avec une reprise notamment que je m'en
fous pas mal d'une certaine dit piaf et
ses rebelles d' antisociale sont ils
toujours aussi rebelle anti sociale
difficile de parler de traces de sang
mentionné ce titre leur titre
pourrait-on même dire sorti en 1980 est
toujours d'actualité mais oui bernie
bonvoisin et norbert nono krief
s'inspire toujours de cette actualité
ils sont toujours rebelle est le nouveau
favori c'est de se faire une idée
[Musique]
merci
et dire tout
les jambes
[Musique]
j'ai aussi trust est en tournée depuis
2016 et donc pour leurs 40 ans une scène
francilienne celle de la merise à
trappes
c'est le samedi 24 novembre à 20h30 et
je ne sais pas vous grégory mais je ne
résiste pas à conclure ce coup de coeur
avec leurs titres un antisocial
des années de service
mais bon
je
[Musique]
merci mélanie et votre émission le 7-8
culture est à retrouver dans un instant
c'est la fin du set 8 journal belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]